congratulations to you you've uh
prospered you've done quite well
for yourself i mean uh every time i turn
around you're in another great project
dolomite is my name you're in you're in
this
movie terrific job yeah it's a terrific
job
thank you very much it was really an
absolute honor to
to work with eddie murphy and wesley
snipes they have like a comedy hero and
an action hero
an action hero hero uh have a comedy
hero in an action hero and be able to be
sandwiched in between have you not
worked with any murphy
no no i had not and he's i mean he's
eddie murphy
is partially responsible for me sitting
in this chair right now i wouldn't have
built that chair he built the chest
he's a very good car very good carpenter
and a pulse term
absolutely yeah um so i mean i i look to
him so much he's one of my comedy idols
i would be uh i have had the opportunity
to meet him and talk to him and
i i noticed that you know in this
business we get to meet everybody we
get to meet presidents and then uh you
you meet someone who you've been
watching
since uh a fairly young age who's just
been a superstar all your life or
as far back as you can remember in your
teenage years eddie murphy i was nervous
were you nervous oh i was i was that's
definitely nervous yeah i remember the
first day that we shot i was sitting on
set
and i i was doing two acting jobs at
once one is to to like make sure you
know the lines for the scene
and the other one was don't freak out
like the entire
like i'm still i'm just sitting there
going i'm like do i look like i'm
looking for a reflective
surface anywhere in the room like do i
look i look like i'm not completely
losing i look like a guy who's cool
around
yeah this because this always says
school right like have i
pooped myself no okay i'm pretty good
i'm in good shape but
but uh and then someone broke the ice
and asked eddie a question and i was
craig robinson craig robinson was like
you know he asked i did a question and
eddie was so gracious in just answering
the question
and was happy to tell us the story and
the guys he's full of stories
and and and then i kind of calmed down a
little bit but then
there was a day so that was helpful that
that was the first time because i came
into a situation where we hadn't seen
just the two of us and he was amazing
it's just he's
when you're while you're you're always
people are afraid to meet their idols
sometimes but you
but he was it was ah it was unbelievable
did you ever get a chance to try and
make him laugh or did you not want to
even try
i didn't i didn't want to try and i
inadvertently made him laugh
and i don't even know what i said i
don't even know what i said
i just heard this cackle and by the way
just so everybody knows eddie murphy
that that is his genuine lack
if you get that's the real laugh if you
can get him to go if you can get that to
go
that means you actually made a lab just
by the way so there
from the 80s not his real life not the
real one in fact that he even said he
goes that was the 1980s laughs that was
the 80s laughing
oh who who you're changing laughs i love
that he retired a lot
he returned he retired you know that's
how i urinated in the 90s you know
it's a natural bodily reaction you're
like no i retired that
right yes so that was it so i don't
remember what i said and i
i apparently was like asking a question
and somebody said something and then i
responded again and then i heard that
yeah in the corner and i was like
that's eddie's lap that's the eddie real
life what up who's she laughing at yeah
yeah who's laughing at you what me
what'd i say that's like what did i
say i have no idea what i said oh my
gosh i bet if you looked it up you'd be
like yeah you'd be like wait that was
taping something right yeah